[Music]
welcome to waters world I'm Jesse waters
the waters Awards that is the subject of
tonight's waters words now in honor of
the Academy Awards this weekend our
producers thought it would be fun to
host our own award show let's begin with
our first category Best Actor in a
political drama here are the nominees
Cory Booker are at the Cavanaugh
confirmation hearing I'm going to
release the email about racial profiling
and I understand that that the penalty
comes with potential I'll sting from the
Senate I openly invite and accept the
consequences this is about the closest
I'll probably ever have in my life to an
I am Spartacus moment just see Smollett
on GMA he said this maggot country
punches me right in the face so I posted
the back the camera and facing north how
is that my issue I want that video found
so badly and I want a little gay boy who
might watch this to see that I fought
back I'm pissed off how do you not
believe that it's the truth and Rachel
Maddow on MSNBC Trump administration
officials have been sending babies and
other young children
Oh put up the graphic of this thank you
do we have it
no and the winner is
Jesse smih lets on GMA that was a
runaway winner right there folks all
right next category best fight scene
here are the nominees Donald Trump
versus Jim Acosta
that's enough for me ma'am so what CNN
should be ashamed of itself having you
working for them you are a rude terrible
person
No Senator Marco Rubio versus a radio
talk show host Alex Jones that's why the
Deepak woman didn't work here's a
question don't touch me again I'm just
beat me oh I'd love to see that
Senator Lindsey Graham versus all of the
Democrats at the Cavanaugh hearing what
you've done to this guy this is the most
unethical sham since I've been in
politics and if you really wanted to
know the truth
you sure as hell wouldn't have done what
you've done to this guy this is going to
destroy the ability of good people to
come forward because of this crap and
the winner is Trump versus Jim Acosta
and with an honorable mention for the
White House intern to had to get her
hands a very dirty all right
next category most politically correct
all right here are the nominees the
University of Maryland for creating a
support group for white students who
feel quote confused before during or
after interactions with minorities all
right also nominated northeastern
professor Suzanna Walters a genndy
gender studies professor who wrote that
men should quote step away to make room
for
women as they quote have every right to
hate you and our final nominee Minnesota
State University professor Eric sprinkle
who said that the Virgin Mary did not
give consent to become pregnant with
Jesus Christ okay and the winner is
Minnesota professor sprinkle that was an
easy one
Frankel I thought there was an
immaculate conception you can set for
that new category best political comedy
here are the nominees President Donald
Trump they go back home to mommy they
get punished when they get home a show
now headed by sleepy eyes Chuck Todd
he's a sleeping son of a [ __ ] daaang
richard blumenthal I watched him saying
we need the truth if we don't have and
he's a guy who was saying people would
dying all around him and he was never
there CNN's Jim Acosta at the border
here are some of the steel slats that
the president's been talking about right
here as a matter of fact it's pretty
tranquil down here of course it is Jim
and Kanye West shocks the press in the
Oval Office
I'm married to a family that uh you know
not a lot of male energy going on it's
about when I put this hat off and made
me feel like Superman
I'm political nope put the beep on it
this is our president he has to be the
freshest the fliers the flying planes
you you are tasting a fine wine and the
winner is Donald Trump he wins it every
year it's just not fair Jim was a close
second last but not least the dumbest
political commentary our nominees are
bado O'Rourke you know would you if you
could would you take the wall down now
here yes like you have a wall absolutely
knock it down I'll take the wall
anything taking the wall down Elizabeth
Warren you know the president likes to
call my mom a liar what are the facts a
fact that you can absolutely have a
Native American ancestor in your
pedigree
[Music]
sure and Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
Millennials and people have you know Gen
Z and all these folks that come after us
are looking up and we're like the world
is going to end in 12 years if we don't
address climate change and your biggest
issue your your biggest issue is how are
we gonna pay for it and like this is the
war this is our world war two world's
gonna end how long how many years and
the winner is Pocahontas Elizabeth
Warren who revealed through a DNA test
that she was not Native American even
though she claims she was that is it for
the waters awards I'd like to thank all
of our winners for their outstanding
work this year and for the losers better
luck next time